tonight on Kitchen Nightmares Gordon
goes to Los Angeles and discovers a
pizzeria on its last leg see movie terms
you've gone straight to DVD Gordon has
one week to take this restaurant from
two thumbs down here we go Q action
drama to a box office
smash but with a boss who's in la la
land my pizzas will be in supermarkets
what Sebastian's all over the world oh
my God and a spaced out menu we have a
concept what we have is 20 different
combinations this may be his toughest
challenge yet that guy needs therapy a
damn good cook and when the owner flips
out this is my life we're done
get the camera out of here and breaks
all the rules he just changed like Dr J
Gordon gives him a cold review but I've
never ever ever ever met someone I
believe him as little as you tonight on
Kitchen
Nightmares
[Music]
Burbank California home to Major
Hollywood Studios whose employees enjoy
dining and making deals at the local
restaurants but there's one restaurant
that is not benefiting from this
location and it's in financial hell it's
a neighborhood Pizzeria called Sebastian
named after its owner who is also a
part-time actor and who's about to
receive much needed help from Gordon
Ramsey how's everything going I've own
the restaurant for a little over 2 years
I can cook anything that's a sandwich
and my mother's been teaching me since I
could walk so I guess that's my formal
training my ability is endless put it in
front of me and I'll make the dish for
you I'll eat it my
myself I think I'm very polite to my
staff this is unbelievable treat him
great L very understanding I think this
is filthy this is ridiculous when he's
get upset you might see pans flying
across the kitchen better duck that's
all I have to say ask him do one damn
thing one thing this is why we're losing
money Sebastian you know he's kind of
abrasive at
times sometimes the things he says are
like what I me it's a big joke to
everybody right big joke they're not
paying the bills people are scared of
Sebastian this is ridiculous I just
don't deal with crap I don't do you make
something wrong I've told you how to
make it six times I have no problem with
firing you I have no problem at all I
fired 49 people in the last year I'm
trying as hard as I can I'm still
getting used to the to the menu have you
guys been here
before it gets exhausting explain the
menu I know it's it's overwhelming I've
created a unique menu that nobody else
has we have 23 Gourmet um flavor
combinations there's 21 Gourmet flavor
combinations there 20 Gourmet flavor
combinations
wait pick a flavor combination and then
you add to beef chicken Portell mushroom
or steak
shrimp wait can I start over so the meat
is in the combination if I saw it I can
do it I mean cuz no no it's chicken let
me start over let me look at it real
quick that's seriously the menu
the majority of the servers are actors
and we all know it's really expensive to
live in LA and so we need to make money
but Sebastian doesn't do a good job at
running Sebastian did something go in
over there I'd say 90% of the time we
are losing money call him daddy hey mama
hey my wife originally invested probably
about
$300,000 what's up buddy what's up mama
I'm very fortunate she does make good
money uh just a check yeah I wish we
need checks I basically control all of
the cash the investment gets to be
resentful because it's so daunting I did
$490 to all day it's hard sometimes to
look at my wife and let her know that I
I don't have the
money if things don't change here at
Sebastian hey guys I don't see us open
longer than 6 more months I really don't
it's 8:00 and uh there's nobody here so
so we're going to go let's we're good
right out of here it would be very sfe
for this place to close because I love
this
place coming in dayto day and trying to
deal with that it takes every bit of
strength I have sometimes to really hold
[Music]
on live music wood fire breakfast plasma
TVs sebastians finally found it um is
here right in amongst all these Studios
and on the front out there very
tacky my
God yes yeah Gordon how are you yes chef
Gordon how are you sir thank yourself
pleasure to meet you no wife working
here with Chef Gordon Ramsey it's like
as an actor having uh Robert dairo say
you know what I'm going to help you with
this role man let me take a seat please
I'll go this one here actually okay
thank
you do you all Ser do I serve no but I
do greet and meet every customer that
walks in the door Jesus every single
customer whether I come over and just
say hello or I spend 10 minutes sit down
and have a glass of wine with you you
sit down with the customers and drink
wine why
[Music]
not oh F me
Christ there's uh photographs on the
menu there's pictures are these real
these photographs yes they are S I took
those myself it looks
ghastly I've always had one simple room
yes sir whenever you come across a menu
with photographs get the out of
there our menu concept is very unusual
and
unique I love the variety would you like
a walk through of our main concept of
the of the
menu concept we have a concept please
over here is our main concept of the
restaurant what we have is 20 different
combinations of marinades toppings and
Seasonings what you do is you choose one
and then you add it to either chicken
Cella mushroom New York strip or shrimp
Angus ribey Prime Cut that's cut for
sebastians you can have one of these
combinations with an entree with chips
and gravy on the side if you'd like with
one of our side salads you see his face
he sit there explain in the menu and
ship Gordon looks like his head's going
to
explode available at any point in time
we have a half PB Angus Prime Burger I
had actually 20
more are you serious yes sir God I've
never heard such a complex menu in my
entire life probably not okay um okay
I'm going to start with some um calamari
calamari yes um they're fresh yes it is
small portion of calamari um Chef Gordon
question the the quality of the calamari
uh my calamari is fresh and then for um
M tray I'd like to have a New York strip
okay can you make me a little uh fresh
pizza what type of would you
like thank
you l me up a small dough
please and what's your name Sonia Sonia
good to see you nice to meet you what
did you do um I'm an actress you're an
actress yes I am what her up did you
play with
Sebastian cuz he's an actor oh no okay I
haven't and the calamari are they fresh
or they frozen they are Frozen
[Music]
Frozen he told me they're
fresh and they're not fresh they're
frozen that confirms two things
chef and a dishonest
one can I get you
anything no the sck
bag he asked me for a sick bag which I
didn't know what to say so I was like
okay oh God he said that he wanted a
puke bag excellent fantastic I didn't
know what to say though you don't have
to say anything okay say yes sir and
walk away okay no problem okay Sebastian
just you could tell in his face that he
wasn't very happy with the comment I
understand the guy's a professional but
to say something like that a sick bag
come
on this is the house speciality um yes
yes and what kind of piece is it what FL
it's a popey pizza popey yes thank you
you're
welcome
hello hey hey so I got the chef here
Chef Gordon Ramsey oh yeah yeah he's in
the dining room eating oh really yeah he
uh he thinks my food is terrible he
thinks your food is terrible yep the
waitress asked can I get you anything
else he said yeah a sick bag go yeah I
don't agree with his opinion throw him
out throw him out yeah yeah with two
wood burning ovens there I thought at
least they would be able to be in a
position to do a stunning pizza but Bas
is it's all watery surely to Christ they
make a fresh piece of dough
here
son I want you to play it to him and I
want you to say as Sebastian's mother
would say mja mja
yeah and Sebastian's mother would say
mja my God it's very difficult to M you
without
of course I'm sorry I should have
brought you a clean one you've got the
part relax
okay it looks like a can of dog food or
an embarrassment to New York strip
[Music]
steak just chopped and cooked to Hell
everything's under seasoned enough
canned pet food for
[Music]
today right now okay in my mind I'm
hoping that you can act because you
clearly can't cook the food was shocking
the calamari weren't even fresh why do
you need to lie to me on a professional
front calamari they're fresh yes it is
they are Frozen Frozen not going to buy
top calamari to mix in the seafood medle
when out a fourstar restaurant
everything is cooked to order even our
hamburgers that we just started making
we make fresh pizza dough pizza dough No
that comes in flash frozen for us I
thought pizza was your speciality I
thought that's what this place was famed
for no sir our men our menu that concept
that baffles you that's what we're
famous for that's why they're queuing up
at the door and you're packing them in
right now um I don't know why my
business isn't the so you're telling me
now that those 20 combinations is
something that's blown your customers
away unbelievably everyone blowing them
the other end of the
world I was basically kicked in the face
to me that shows ignorance and a lack of
respect I I truly have no respect for
the man and his Awards it they mean
nothing to me at this point okay my pizz
soon will be in supermarkets what I
would love to franchise this and have a
sebastians all over the world oh my God
just think how that sounds sebastians
all over the world that makes me excited
you haven't got one right so far
how the can you think about
two I need some fresh air the guy's
gone this guy is seriously off his
trolley I just want won that one
I won that one what on Earth is going on
in his up delusional mind woo I
won that one I want that one what
happened he was giving me and I
gave it back to me and it was like uh
whatever yeah hello Chef um I just want
a little
word listen big boy right now you've won
Jack you've got the
audacity to stand there talking to me
about franchise when we can't even get a
pizza right it took everything in me not
to just freak out I've been here 2 years
it may not to show what I have got to
show I'll tell you what I have to show
pride pride you're delusional that is
your opinion sir a lot of people feel
that way about
you what's successful about out there
I'm still here that's what makes it
successful you just answered my question
I'll see you later yeah me woo
that I think get one that one
yes coming up Gordon finds that when it
comes to cooking it's frozen frozen
frozen Sebastian thinks Inside the Box
you're happy to be a fake Chef aren't
you and later when Sebastian loses it
this is my life we're done get
the camera out of here Gordon tells it
like it is I've never ever ever ever met
someone I believe in as little as
you coming up on K
nightmares after a lunch that was not
only disappointing but confusing Gordon
returns to observe a dinner
service what's up
beautiful good to see
you I'm going to come on and have a beer
with you guys nice yes we get a lot of
directors producers you know industry
people coming in yeah man holy I'm
like how do I know this guy the majority
of the servers are actors rappers his
models I'm a model myself I've gotone a
couple gigs off working at Sebastian's
how you doing brother good to see you
Sebastian is the young who's who of
Hollywood but for these young actors
their biggest performance happens
nightly when they have to sell
Sebastian's over complicated
menu okay let me explain the menu to you
it's a little bit different there's 20
gourme flavor combination you decide if
you want chicken portella mushroom New
York STP it can take up to like 20
minutes because there's so many
different combinations and so many
different options you have on our menu
then you decide if you would like it in
a roll as a sandwich on a bit of lettuce
as a salad or just as an
entree I can't even to much stuff while
the waitress's struggle with the menu
Gordon hopes to observe Sebastian
leading the kitchen but that is not the
case cute I'm selling a table uh 100 I
got the cilano give me the shrimp
Pittsburgh with a capry salad it's
coming in 20 seconds I love to cook
that's my passion I love to cook so it's
crazy but my strong point is when we
busy all it is all it this right all all
of
this it's
frozen and then you deep fry it that
goes in a burger butn bloody H is there
anything that's ever cooked homemade not
very very rare L very rare and what you
put in there this is just the potatoes
we just piping through and you make
fresh cream potatoes I believe it comes
has frozen yet Frozen so what do you do
to it we just heat it up you just heat
it up so it's not even powdered match
it's already made in the factory and it
comes
in processed mashed
potato noticing the lack of fresh
food Gordon heads to the fridge to
confirm his suspicions and what he finds
is a key reason as to why the restaurant
is failing well it's definitely
processed a fridge stocked with
prepackaged frozen food nothing's fresh
made this all bought in sauces yes sir
this one's a buying yes yes Buy in yes I
don't think we should be serving as much
of the stuff that we do out of cans I
think that most of the stuff we serve
out of cans we could probably make that
in-house where is your uh your bought in
dough and to Gordon's amazement even the
pizza dough is Frozen at this pizzaeria
and you get them in Frozen Yes com in
Frozen I think it's one of the best
frozen dos I've seen and uh it's the
only way we can right now to save a
dollar I got to be in there with the
presence of a worldclass chef in the
house Sebastian decides it's time to
take over in an attempt to impress Chef
ramsy B Lou pizza that's three work here
okay thank you very much I got it Lou I
can do it I can do it if I just moved
Lou to another station where I thought
she'd be uh more useful at that point
and I could kind of just regain things I
have no idea why he asked me to come
over here next Pizza you guys have I
want to make I was really wanting to
show Gordon that my ability is endless
there's nothing I can't cook put it in
front of me and I'll make
it how's it going man that's
history but they taste better than they
look and to make matters worse this
pizzeria's most important cooking device
is not the pizza ovens but a
microwave water up holy
now Sebastian's carelessness is
affecting the
[Music]
customers I had a salad go out and it
had a hair in it is it yours it's not my
hair because it's not Dad no I don't
want to see you eat it the waitress came
over to me and told me that there was a
hair in her
salad what happened I just chok a piece
of hair out of my mouth I was eating the
salad a piece of hair it was going down
my throat and then
my friend saw me pull it out of my mouth
I'm going to make you a fresh new salad
in just a few moments I don't think I
want another
salad the salad's gone and so is your
pizza pizza's on us tonight thank you
you're welcome food that was comp there
was uh $300 worth of food comp tonight
it we got that one coming out we
up this one this one's on the
house make some friends make some
friends come on pay attention with
dinner service coming to an end Gordon
has many
concerns are you okay hey I need
somebody over here to get some of these
plates going not the least of them being
that the owner seems to be
unconcerned you'll come back tomorrow
I'll be sitting on the same couch curled
up with a bottle of vodka just
going talking to myself how are you Chef
fine thank you and you I'm doing okay
chilling out with your buddies uh yes I
am he didn't think that that was is uh
professional did you need me Chef I need
2 minutes with you on your own okay I'm
going to get inside and uh work you guys
going to hang out for a little bit Yeah
I was kind of upset at Chef Gordon at
that point um I I felt like he was being
a little unreasonable let's just have a
little taste
[Music]
together what does that taste for you
it's straight it's a little dry it's cut
the end off squeeze it into the
container and send it a lot of stuff
isn't homemade 95% of the stuff is
bought in uh okay I I was going to go
with 80% this is the most
disgusting Bor in crap that
taste in my entire
life it's almost more important for me
to let this go out at half its quality
and go out and make sure that the guests
are happy and meet the guest and talk to
them you're happy
to be a fake Chef on no because I don't
believe I'm a fake Chef it's a
franchisable concept why are you so
obsessed with becoming famous
with a franchise why can't you just have
a restaurant and cook your ass off and
get customers in here for the love of
what you're doing I was hoping that this
would be my launching pad for my name
how that's not cooking if you are
convinced in your mind that what you're
doing is going to work you're beyond
reach you know that
really me up next Gone the old menu
is Gone With the Wind is a confusion but
a new menu I don't see any uniqueness
has Sebastian seeing red and later my
life we're done get the camera
out of here he just changed like Dr J
Gordon gives Sebastian the painful truth
never ever ever ever met someone I
believe in as little as you coming up on
Kitchen
Nightmares in a town known for its
movies tonight's dinner service is a
major
flop the nominees for the most confused
restaurant in Hollywood is
sebastians
sebastians and
and your most famous words tonight was
not any form of Delegation organizing
Insight it's on
me comp that one I'll take care of that
bill serve that to there you're running
a business not a freebie drive by pick
up and go home you shouldn't be saying
that at 10: to 9: in the middle of a
bloody busy
night what do we comp in terms of
dollars probably close to
300 300 bucks yeah I don't know
what to say working with Gordon is going
to be a challenge I felt like he was
being a little
unreasonable here's the
thing what needs to happen here big
change we will
have a new
menu are you all
[Music]
right
it's day two and after yesterday's
eye-opening observations it's time for
Gordon to get through to this stubborn
chef with prepackaged and frozen food
turning customers off Gordon gets the
staff headed in a new direction to take
advantage of the pizza ovens which up
until now have been used just for show
and not for cooking sebastians yes yes
needs to become known for one thing and
one thing only fresh pizza what are
those two things there pizza ovens this
place can become so popular for homemade
fresh wood burning pizza I'm not making
the money and it's quite expensive to
really start using fresh dough again
guys come here have you or you or you
ever tossed a pizza dough no no not here
all of you yeah are now going to become
great tossers I've got two phenomenal
expert tossers here now gentlemen come
in please come and say hello Gordon
brought in a couple of gu to show us how
to be pizza tossers and everything it is
just like going to Ben hunas and
watching them chop your food and cook it
right at the table I think this looks
wonderful in front of customers if I
would sat here with my family watching
you do this a hug differ it does now
yeah I want you to become the perfect
tosser hell you have a go yes you let's
go guys all of us yeah I'm up for a
challenge and willing to try something
new
go only thing I hate about that whole
thing is I had to get rid of my nails
but other than not I love the fresh
pizza
dough okay guys let's go at this point
in the game one of two things has to
happen I have to accept what he says and
go with him or ask him to
leave coming up when the kitchen heats
up Sebastian starts to crack okay can
Gordon reain him in I'm stepping away
from it cuz I don't want to be too close
you ungrateful you have no idea nasty
idea Joker you that's it is
it coming up on Kitchen Nightmares it's
day three while Gordon took the day to
get the staff focused on fresh food and
using the brick pizza ovens his design
team worked overnight to transform the
restaurant good morning guys ladies how
are we well I'm excited to see the
changes such a Decor guys ready yes
don't drop the baby yeah I'm going to
take go go go go go go go
R first minute I walked in this space it
was ridiculous it feels new and fresh
yes
it's just overwhelming the way the place
[Music]
look oh my oh my goodness new chairs new
couches new linen little bar there to
serve your cocktails from this is great
this is so
gorgeous you start to see just a nice
vibrant clean
look wow it looks new Sebastian the
first time I've heard you lost the words
yes you're speechless huh it's
absolutely
beautiful Lou happy very very very good
this is huge it's bigger than big I just
cannot describe how happy and over where
I am now one more thing okay we got rid
of the frozen pizza dough because from
this day on you're now going to be
making your own
dough is that is the best of the best it
is an extraordinary piece of equipment L
come over my dny you wanted fresh dough
in here is that right rumor has it now
you can make fresh dough to your heart
you know that I was overwhelmed I was
looking at that mixer it was phenomenal
now you really got your work cut out my
darling you know that okay good this is
the start yeah of Sebastian's turning
around there's no excuse anywhere from
Decor to wood burning oven to vibrant
attitude from the staff the real work
starts tonight there's no excuse
although Sebastian craves success he has
been resistant to change and now he's
about to face his biggest fear first
thing we'll do is play to our strengths
okay kind of noticed that he was holding
two menus one being mine and one being
the change that I think I was most
afraid of and uh that really made me
nervous what I'm going to confirm now is
that the confusion has gone gone
yeah is a confusion gone is Sebastian's
20 ingredient mix and match flavor menu
with pre-processed frozen food it looks
like a can of dog food and in its place
are made to order items using fresh and
homemade ingredients just have a look
let me read you through the menu first
okay pizzas all cooked order on our very
own wood burning oven a margarita a
salami a vegetarian and then the Entre
grilled New York steak and a wood
burning oven cooked chicken there's
nothing quite like this currently going
on in this neighborhood you have got an
amazing chance to succeed here if you
keep it simple I like the new menu
simple the fresh product and the fresh
dough that's a big thing for me take
away the intimidation of Bastion play to
your strengths use what you've got when
Gordon showed us the new menu I think it
was a bit overwhelming for Sebastian's
here are you upset there's no photos on
there there's uh photographs on the menu
there's pictures of the food I took
those
myself no no the photos uh isn't the
thing that I'm concerned of it's just uh
it's it's it's the change I was scared
of are you worried about the size of the
menu no the size isn't the concern it's
uh I don't see any uniqueness you're not
going to now ask me to turn around and
say what you gave me in terms of pizza
was unique I've created a unique menu
that nobody else has and Chef Gordon
said I quote him I've never seen a menu
like this before so I'm assuming that
it's quite unique to him also stop
trying to be too clever don't try to be
too smart if you are you know anxious
about 20
combinations it's 20 times confusing I
thought that'd be more compromised with
my menu I didn't expect it to be just
completely gone I love that
menu you tried for 2 and a half years
and it hasn't worked that's the end of
that
chapter
with the Academy Awards falling on the
same night as the relaunch Gordon
decides that this coincidence should be
taken advantage of and is rolling out
the red carpet for an Oscar night party
and Sebastian's is fully booked we're
going to kick ass and everything going
to be a whole lot better tonight I like
to see this place
[Music]
Rock tonight expect a lot of chaos but
it should be
fun I'm fighting right now still inside
about that menu it's driving me crazy
right now in my head hey we're serving
we're serving you know 100 people in 20
minutes with the kitchen hard at work
with last minute preparations Sebastian
is still brooding over Gordon's overhaul
of his
menu I think it's a big joke to
everybody
right this place is a mess nobody wants
to clean okay F uh Sebastian where is he
send everybody home and do the
[Music]
myself
where's Sebastian all in his office in
his
office this place is a mess and the
waiters they they can't even clean I got
to come in and vacuum the rugs what is
that about one minute he can be the
happy go-lucky Sebastian and then who
put this cheer on the floor this is what
I'm talking about and then we wonder why
we're losing
business
okay anybody going to get the
phone
[Music]
this it's Oscar night and more
importantly relaunch night at
Sebastian's I'm very excited and we're
just going to have so much fun with the
new
everything wherever you want grab seek
I'm really excited to prove to Chef
Gordon that we can actually do something
right and all though there's excitement
in the air Sebastian is feeling one
thing more than anything else where's
Sebastian pressure this is ridiculous
Sebastian excuse me
sir okay 2
seconds um control it whether you're
running the pizza side or whether they
on the grill as those orders come in
push them out get on top of it and make
sure that everyone is not shouting
across each other one person controlling
it yes okay any questions no sir no good
you let's
go already the restaurant is buzzing
about the new
menu Willow your mind how they are this
time
around pleas the roast have chicken okay
we have the P you're going to try the
shrip nikk you're going to love it so
far everybody really likes the new menu
it's really nice and the first wave of
orders is now hitting the kitchen I got
two margaritas in okay good tonight the
pizzas are selling great these trim
nikkis are going like crazy like crazy
what the margarita and the Sal a small
sew it SE it an hour into service and
the new simplified menu is enabling the
kitchen to run smoothly and the orders
are getting out in good time this has
got rot cheese Mozzarella cheese and
spinach so good you guys keep in mind
all the dough is all homemade enjoy I
hope you like it and Gordon's new made
to order Entre are impressing the
customers
great the shrimp tastes good the night
is going very well a lot of people are
enjoying the new food cuz they think
it's really
fresh much better much much better but
instead of being happy Sebastian is
still Disturbed over the menu change
that's hey look at that yeah and think
frozen mashed
potatoes no
comparison
um I want to try to go back to all those
20 flavor combinations there's a lot of
uniqueness with the menu I was using
whether he thought it was good food or
bad food it was unique Sebastian still
doesn't fully support Gordon's mandate
for freshness this is gone this is gone
you got to pull them tickets and before
the night is over the microwave is back
in
Action make me a prim off the new menu
or off the old menu no the old menu
all right a prima an anti pasty and
another
Pittsburgh okay I need to know what
Sebastian did here cuz this is a mess
unfortunately Sebastian's reversion to
his old menu has caused confusion in the
kitchen I need this to
35 was that 35 what you just sent out
right yeah no this is table three and
this no I think the that's a sign Erica
get her get her get her I need that
sandwich have a chicken farm sandwich
got it got it I can only tell you from a
server standpoint it was almost like a
domino effect once one thing started
happening then another
another hey Sebastian I can tell you
right now we're going to need some help
over here so I can take table I have
okay this is what happen no 91 91
11 the scampy is gone for Table 9 I
handed it right there we started using
old menu and and there was so much
confusion in the
kitchen so the old menu now yeah I love
the new menu but I the original concept
of Sebastian with the 20 flavor
combinations I'll never lose that no
way we serving the old menu me
looks like something for dog's
dinner no way no no no no I just
wanted to know what would happen if I
wasn't here are you serious you think no
I'm asking yeah I'm just asking don't
stop it's going cold
here we go Q action drama
me welcome guys I hope you enjoy your
pizza oh dear it appears as though
Sebastian's ego is getting in the way of
his potential success and Gordon's had
enough Sebastian I knew I ended word
with you first right my
man you can talk to me anyway he wants
but when it comes down to it I know what
I'm doing okay when I first arrived here
we got off to a shaky start sure think
about it oh yeah and then we kept our
heads down and we got through it
together yes we did and we made some
really exciting changes the menu's
changed the staff have changed
yes mate there's one thing that hasn't
changed in this establishment and that's
you
Sebastian I'm 40 years of age and I've
gone to a lot of restaurants but I've
never ever ever
ever met someone I believe in as little
as
you I think that you will go
back to your sloppy shortcut 5 out of 10
Frozen
[Music]
wavs good
luck unbelievable unfuckin believable
useless you kidding me
kidding me right
now this is my
life oh my god this is my
life honestly I haven't seen Sebastian
dis
emotional Sebastian just got real out he
just changed like Dr J and must High you
K
me that's pissed on his buire
arrogant that
we're done get the camera out of
[Music]
here Chef
Gordon Chef Gordon where the are
you where are you I'm here you come into
my restaurant yes I'm just so
disappointed you going to count down
stop your finger at me are we going to
speak like men you going to speak to me
like a man you didn't listen to what
list to what I'm saying did you just
hear what I just told you I'm stepping
away from you cuz I don't want to be too
close you ungrateful you have no idea
you have no my idea Joker
you that's it is it yeah it is it
you're very disappointing second
performance tonight are you
kidding me your whole Act is a
joke anything else your whole Act is a
joke you're a phony you
shouldn't run like that run like what am
I supposed to be scared now Sebastian
come on give me a break I busted my ass
in there you tell me are you kidding me
are you kidding me let me just tell you
something you ain't telling me nothing
I'm done I'm done you get your bit yes
loser I'm telling you one last time
you're a
loser I'm telling you one last
time you're a while
Sebastian lets off steam
Outside Inside the kitchen has come to a
halt Gordon has put an enormous amount
of effort into Sebastian's he has also
been impressed by the staff's
willingness to change they look lovely
don't they huh are they going out
now wow it's hard to
hear that what you've done is a
failure come on guys salmon and chicken
away yeah roasted vegetables let's go
it's uh it's true some of the stuff he
says maybe I was a little twisted with
my ideas and my goals if you look at the
numbers then I guess it looks like I'm
feeling
okay ready happy little size of lemon
knife please it's a slap of reality and
I know he's
right it's not easy to
accept but I guess before you grow you
got to accept it keep them in there get
them nice and
yeah it's my family my my kids makes you
want to work harder let's go what's next
can you talk to me Big Boy shrimp yeah
good I don't have the degree I didn't go
to school I know I've Got Talent I'm a
damn good cook I'm not giving up I'll
get there I'll get
[Music]
there everyone's just kind of looking
around and we didn't know what was going
to
[Music]
happen
I was speechless I didn't couldn't even
tell you how worried I was cuz um he's
supposed to be this big bad guy right I
could feel him watching me I felt like
he was said what are you going to do
about your kitchen it's falling apart
I'm like you're right I got I got I got
to fix this how we
looking are we we back on top now where
are you on top yeah not confused
[Applause]
good Sebastian just came in and he was
ready to go give me a large crustini I
got you AB perfect perfect perfect once
things started going smoothly Sebastian
seemed to be a lot more optimistic get a
little excited in here I appreciate the
enthusiasm the fact I've got one in a
million opportunity here I'd be a fool
not to accept it t send it out let's
go Salmon's gone yes 11 let's go up up I
need us out on the fly with Sebastian
back in the saddle the staff rallies to
together and turns the kitchen around
service has stepped up food is going out
on time and most importantly the
customers are
[Music]
happy bloody well done you took on the
changes well you all adapted change is a
challenge it's hard but I think it'll be
worth it in the long run it's everything
that we've worked for Lou Your
Enthusiasm is infectious you know that
coming from Chef Gordon made me feel
really good to know that that he saw
that in me so that was cool Andre happy
very yes yes yeah we started off slow
but hey we didn't crumble did we we got
more adjusted to the menu and things
started working a lot more smoothly for
us tomorrow it starts again yes well
done yes up up
up very
good I respected Chef when he came in my
opinion changed of him when I met
him and he's reiterated to
me I don't have to agree with his
methods the result is what it is as Al
Le Sebastian I have a lot of mix
feelings I really know this restant can
be a big success but I also feel
Sebastian has very little interest in
sticking to the new
plan tonight on Kitchen Nightmares
Gordon rides into Taho New York New York
and finds a handyman with a dream that's
become a nightmare it's the last
table but that doesn't mean the owner is
lacking confidence I don't believe
there's a better operator or restaurant
tour than me read the ticket the
rather odd menu has turned customers off
like could come out of a baby's diaper
right that hiss on top the chef has lost
his way do I still have passion for food
please help me no and if Gordon can't
get through to this control freak owner
you're a fake well you're a this
restaurant will have no choice but to
close every ship plate of food we send
we're narrowing the chances of this
place becoming successful can Gordon
restore order to the Old Stone Mill I'm
not too sure if you're actually hungry
for the change you know that or have
they grown accustomed to chaos are we
scared about being busy yes what tonight
on Kitchen
Nightmares
[Music]
chaho New York a wealthy old commuter
Town 45 minutes north of Manhattan and
home to the Old Stone Mill restaurant
and bar but now the Old Stone Mill is in
danger of grinding to a halt for good
okay 6 years ago I I took this place
and I began my quest to convert this Old
Mill into a restaurant and here we are
open 4 years now done we took a risk
there's no investors here you know we
built it out I did everything in here
myself is this the right spot all the
woodwork the carpentry the plumbing the
only thing I really didn't get involved
in was the electrical
work okay I don't believe there's a
better oper Ator or restaurant tour than
me but no one's coming in or trying to
come in embarrassed that I can't go out
with the sides that I need for a table
my boss Dean he's painy ass he has come
in and screamed at me come on man read
the tickets it's horrible it's
absolutely horrible what the do I
still have passion for
food no and it
shows there were days I just couldn't
think of eating the food
I eat my food and my family eats my food
and I think it's good we don't have a
very young crowd there is a assisted
living facility right behind us and we
do have a lot of the Blu heads come
in that's that's the that's the customer
base hopefully the Entre will come soon
service please we do have a problem with
the service because it is very hard to
get people to work here can I get
someone here to clean this sink missing
a dish here missing a knife little piece
of glass on the table
never heard anyone right I have a
reoccurring nightmare that I've had from
day one what happens if I open up
staffed up food ready and no one decides
to come here well it happened this year
I don't know I don't have answers for
that I wish I did when you're making no
money it's very hard to convince you
that tomorrow is going to be a better
day when you have bills to pay it's not
that nice when it's slow well a slow
night there a lot of sad faces you tell
me what to do well he's tell me what to
do let everybody earn money and let Dean
take it in the ass as always why aren't
more people coming here I don't know I
really really don't know being behind on
my mortgage and the thought of them for
closing on my house I just couldn't I
couldn't take it I can't take it hi
Honey hi babe I need money for dry
cleaning
money what about these people think they
need
money I think my wife might know
these last couple of months have been
the worst ever for me I'm going to be up
here and see who the lucky people are
that are going to get paid today this
restaurant isn't just a restaurant it's
our life it's our future it's our
children's
[Music]
future
beautiful thank you
[Music]
bye we ready to go and himself he'll be
here any minute I almost drove by this
place what a beautiful building what
scares me is why no one's eating here
I'm about to find
out what Gordon how are you I'm dezo
nice to see you well very nice to see
you good to see you too thanks for
coming by no matter what you say the
guy's a winner his Michelin stars are
like World Series rings he's got them
Tom Tom how are you this is the the bman
yes this is the chief cook and bottle
washer here this okay fantastic you know
I know his credentials I know how good
he is I'm starving oh okay I do believe
Gordon could help the restaurant but how
much so I don't know Genie this is
Gordon Ramsey when he approached me and
put out his hand said hello to me well
first of all I like blonde men so he was
adorable Jean nice to see you I felt a
very warm Feeling So Glamorous Gordon
will be a plus in my
life this is our menu just has a little
history on one side and our menu on the
other thank you you got
it how so I'd like to know the crab
cakes are homemade with fresh crab meat
fresh crab meat lovely I'll start off
with crab cake I'd like to see um shrimp
please I'll have the chopped salad
please thank you and then for um main
course risoto and then I'll go for the
taape on
pap
Michael you do things your way I am very
nervous he's going to come in here I'm
going to cook for him and he's going to
say are you um chewing gum yes you are
is that
normal I suppose
ready apart from being slow the waiters
think it's normal to chew gum hey come
on let's go send it out we have somebody
of his caliber come in I don't know what
he's going to do I don't know what he's
going to
[Music]
say oh thank
you it tastes really strange I can't put
my finger on it something really weird
in there it's like a sour mayonnaise
flavor I'm hoping that he likes one of
the dishes that he ordered two of the
dishes maybe all of the dishes
nothing
[Music]
H wrapped in fer past Deep Fat fried
I've eaten some prawns in my life but F
me that's the first not do you help make
it out Gordon is this a popular addition
on the menu yes
wow so far I don't think he's likeed the
[Music]
food what is that chop salad oh chop
salad Sor excuse me look at that what's
that squashed into looks like it's being
squashed into an ice cream
cone okay that's it there right that
sits on top was the chef a
mechanic no no aside from its appearance
that people actually enjoy it you know
this is my house he was in my house and
he was embarrassing
[Music]
me
okay
[Music]
please don't make me eat any all this
take this out while this is still
puffy
please lovely thank
you looks like someone's had a in
the bag and stuck it in the
oven God dud disappointment was written
all over his
face doesn't like any of the food so far
it's gross pretty gross basically told
me everything was serving his what'
you expect him to say everything was
great every single dish he had sucked
you know I I can't help but get
defensive
Roto the chef likes all this little Mash
Lamb's
letters sadly it's hot and disgusting
the rice just pure is in your mouth it
like sort of sticks to the roof of your
mouth well a ran can't even cook a
simple mushroom risoto it's a big worry
Gordon didn't like the food didn't seem
to like anything so nobody's feeling too
good right now if you're going to be
arrested in ter at least know what your
food tastes like I don't think this
guy's got a clue what his food
tastes
like okay take a seat sit down right um
that was interesting um interesting but
bitterly disappointing is that canned
crab that's not fresh crab M it's caned
crab when I ask very politely is the
crab meat fresh the way to told me yes
of course it is the waer told you that
was fresh grab meat yeah that's why I
ordered it first one AR stone cold I'm
sorry let have a little taste that and
eat that for
me look at it it looked like itd come
out of a baby's diaper huh no one's
going to come back for that that is a
chopped salad I mean it's hideous it's
have a taste of
that my 8-year-old daughter could cook
better than that probably from anyone
else I would have threw a table over and
threw them out honestly you food's
[Music]
crap he's a little harsh and he got to
be a little abusive on the
food oh what the hell did we get
into if you think that you're going to
continue running this business serving
that you might as well turn this
place into a museum no one's going to
come back for this I was pissed real
pissed I wanted to take the plate and
smash it on top of the chef's head
coming up Gordon bursts Dean's bubble
I'm not too sure if you're actually
hungry for the change and this owner
boils over that's what I get paid to do
to stand here next to people and give
them a good experience and later
Michael snaps it's been an hour and I
got nothing this is the copy you got to
have the other half this comes from the
salad qu that's coming up on Kitchen
Nightmares
in order to fully understand all the
issues of the Old Stone Mill it's time
to get tight Li Dean to open up and
these questions may not be comfortable
Dean but unless I understand the full
scenario then I can't get this place
back
online one thing I'd like to know is the
financial
situation are you aware of the current
financial situation
B um he kind of keeped me in the dark a
little bit so I don't want how to worry
no reason for her to share these anxiety
and nerves that I have totally
unnecessary I try not to bring it
up it's always easier just to kind of
not think about what's going on here and
that's probably one of the reasons why I
don't come down very often to the
restaurant because what you don't know
can't hurt you I just choose not to deal
with it right now I'll let him deal with
it yeah but if the house gets taken away
and you lose that then every reason to
be
worried I mean the bottom line is you're
losing money correct every week every
week yes if we had to close yeah tonight
just switch everything off yeah what
would we
[Music]
oh half a million half a million
yeah it wouldn't be good for our
marriage I don't think if he would risk
you know everything that we possibly had
in the world got money tied up in the
home mortgage wise oh sure a mortgage a
second mortgage and a home equity line
God so that's backed up big time
yeah how do you manage in terms of
getting through month-to month in terms
of mortgage payments suppliers salaries
your salary what do you want me to say
it's it's you know I'm in hell right
now please don't get upset I know I no
no it's crucial for me to understand
exactly where we are I've got to be
really Frank and honest
that's why you're
[Music]
here nothing is more telling to Gordon
than observing a full dinner service
fortunately it's Saturday night the one
night the restaurant is busy Hi how are
you all right well enjoy your dinner hi
folks how are you I know you'll be happy
with that and can't go wrong tonight I'm
on the edge cuz now the fear of failure
is setting in the cashew chicken prime
rib medium
r as orders begin to arrive in the
kitchen fried C chop salad crab cakes
One Prime rare medium rare two cashew
chicken Chef Michael is clearly
frustrated never see anybody run a line
by themselves I not like this before
no you know it's just me and you have to
get it done you get it done it's not
easy when you buy yourself it really
isn't now I'm not saying it is easy
Michael Works more than is expected of a
normal Chef he does above and beyond and
as Chef Michael continues to fight the
battles alone in the kitchen nice to
meet you Lisa owner Dean and manager Tom
are in their own world in the front of
the house Another Day in Paradise huh hi
how are you perfect I think I might have
a beer with you oh really Cheers Cheers
say the truth there is no place like
this in Pennsylvania there's no place
like
home as the manager here I do whatever
it takes to keep the place running as
smoothly as possible and where's your
strengths your strengthening
what hopefully the Entre will come soon
cuz it's been
should that's
[Laughter]
true an hour into dinner service and the
overly embellished dishes finally emerge
from the kitchen Mike tries to
presentate the food real nice what's
this crack here with calamari and
Martini loss they were just trying
different presentation because the the
dishes we have suck
suck I can't believe you've being so
polite holy
mackerel I don't even know what to tell
you and neither Gordon or the customers
are impressed I think my fist too much
ging okay is it
cold is there enough sauce on these
cashew chickens yes there is I'll more
when it just becomes a job not that you
don't care not that you don't put any
effort but it's just the same every
day by the way the the the paper's
edible I've never had my dinner sech to
me in a paper bagy I don't know why the
fries are looking remarkably shitty to
me in your business right now yeah I
wish that was the only problem the
french fry is it cold send it
back send it back y excuse me you they
okay okay just okay just okay just okay
with food now being sent back to the
kitchen already behind Michael is now
totally overwhelmed I need a one a
tilapia and that's done and Dean is not
helping the problems but adding to them
I got backed up cuz there was too much
at once oh my God overcooked come on
come on get this to get this to 28 booo
right now Mike got a result though it's
overcooked God damn it got me very
frustrated let the customer wait if he
waits 20 minutes and he's happy or he
waits 20 minutes gets crap what's worse
let him wait 20 minutes and be happy
give me that this man please send it out
right now Michael yes sir are you happy
with that Roto not really Chef no
Michael if you're not happy with it why'
you serve it my man Chef to Chef now
forget forget forget Dean where's the
fapia that's what I want right now in
the oven yeah Dean he's the owner
ultimately it's his
decision yeah right now I just want to
get people their
food you want to matter with
this it's very
salty
try your disgusting yeah you should send
it
back does it make you feel better if we
rushed it to the table no I'm trying to
ask the chef about some form of standard
and you're just like get the
out of because the lady asked me
three times for food I'm amazed you know
that more than
anything I don't know I don't know what
I don't know what you want me to say to
you your restant is on the
ass that's what I'm but it's done it's
done Gordon it's done I love the facade
you put across it you know that it's not
a facade yes it is no it's not actually
we were just going to ask you about the
Roto really salty I don't really like
taste of it
all what did they
say they sent back your favorite dish
ISO Dean's willingness to send out
substandard Roto typifies what's wrong
with the Old Stone Mill in addition a
great deal of Dean's energy has gone
into beautifying the
restaurant but the menu has been
neglected I don't think you understand
the real reason why I'm here the
inconsistency of food is
obvious the food needs some serious
attention and yet no one seems to
address it I asked Michael are you happy
with the risoto he said said no and you
said no I've got to serve it I got to
serve it they be waiting 50 minutes have
you any idea how much damage you're
causing what do you want what what do
you want not about what I want it's just
what I'm I'm mythed I'm not too sure if
you're actually hungry for the change
you know that it's one thing to believe
in a dream but it's another thing to
actually be in a Dream World for every
plate of food we
send we're narrowing the chances of this
place becoming successful and I think
you bully them into making sure that
they get
brainwashed to how you
think well let me tell you something
what you think is
wrong it's tough to get poked out all
day I feel like poking back right now
I'm trying to get through to you if I
can't get through to you I've got no
chance I think you're treating this like
a game how dare you accuse me of not
having a commitment how dare you I don't
don't dare you I'm telling you you're
not telling me anything this is your own
figment of your imagination that I don't
have a commitment to this place Dean's a
fighter he's not going to back down from
a challenge did you just give me 2
minutes you guys you mind you float on
the customers coming around blowing
smoke up your ass that's right I do when
I ask people how their food is they tell
me it's good it makes me feel good I
don't R around my customers kissing how
was it please tell me you don't go to
the table ask people had a meal with or
no you you probably PID 10 people to go
to the table I listen to the phone every
morning to see how fully booked
I am this is what I get paid to do just
stand in here that's what I get paid to
do to here next to people and give them
a good experience that's what I
get paid for watch this come out no
that's and feel good about it no I don't
feel good about there you go again
that's my op don't feel good about it
you did that's what I got to do
that's what I do you're a fake you
you're a fake you're a
fate is that how you going to act walk
away you not face it like a
[Applause]
[Music]
man it's what I got to do that's what I
do you're a fake you you're a fake
you're a fake you're full of
is that how you going to act walk
away you not face it like a man
I face everything like a man I don't sh
away from nothing that's right
nothing nothing not you
nothing I have a commitment to this
place that you'll probably never have to
any place in your life ever
what did I stutter I just told you how I
feel about this place I'm not going to
suck your dick to make you believe me if
you don't believe me you don't believe
me you don't like the truth de I do like
the truth no one's your I heard
the truth in my life more than you'll
ever hear the truth yeah that's
what you think you take pride in your
hair your trouser your shirt you you're
well groomed I just want you to take
pride in what the you do in a
business and if you applied what you
applied in yourself each and every day
you won't be serving that right now
we got some issues in here and unless
you're prepared to changeed this place
has got no chance and you've had it all
your own way for such a long
time time and it's not going to continue
being like
that one thing it has to change
instantly
[Music]
you ironically it's Dean's fear of
failure that is preventing him from
making the necessary changes for success
but before Gordon can put his plan for
change into action he decides to explore
the local competition Italian Chinese
restaurant next door to
pizzer an American
P how weird another Italian restaurants
everywhere another Italian my
[Music]
Y how are you very good good to see you
you too and what a beautiful little shop
thank you very much busy little place
very busy fantastic they the great meat
eaters here yes they are they love their
steaks and they like them thick been up
and down the street there's not one
steak house anywhere no there isn't why
do no one ever open one here uh I don't
know but if there was a steakhouse local
you could Supply it it would be a
pleasant change well listen thank you
good to see have a good weekend thank
you Paul Chef thank you again take care
okay sir
[Music]
nice now armed with local knowledge
Gordon knows that to turn this
restaurant around he must get the chef
back on track Michael this restaurant
needs to be known for something
first big change prime rib prime rib on
the bone okay this is a special to get
this place in the right direction to
make your life easier and to make
Service quicker I am very nervous it's
not every day that you get to cook with
a world clar Chef you know how to slice
it from there don't you down and all up
yeah exactly go ahead and put that beef
in you I'm excited to learn those new
dishes and then after time just put my
own spin on him and hope he doesn't come
back and throw me under the bus the idea
behind the chop salad is having that
little bit of crunch there yeah Romain
shredded few chines little bit of bacon
in there half dressed so it stays nice
and crunchy little seasoning on the
avocado your tomato chopped egg two
chives melt down okay yes oh just think
of the complaints what you're not
stuffing my salad in a funnel what do
you mean you're not serving me a funnel
salad Mike you all right with this I'm
fine with that I left my ass off when he
burned those funnels with the cremet
torch I laughed and and I understood his
point there's nothing wrong with a
simple salad don't try and make it
anything that it's not if they come and
ask me for their salad to be stuck
inside a funnel I will personally lift
them and put them next door in the
retirement home okay last of the
[Music]
funnel with the chef re-energized Gordon
turns his attention to the owner and his
team Dean has always had the desire to
succeed now Chef Ramsey is about to tell
him how to do it okay I've done my
homework I've been out and about and I
I've studied hard what isn't in
the
[Music]
town there's not one good Steakhouse
anywhere in this
town this place has got every chance of
becoming a phenomenal
Steakhouse Chef Gordon's idea of a
steakhouse would really work here he's
100% right that there is nothing else in
the area give the locals what they want
and get them come in time and time again
and make money I'm listening to Gordon
I'm listening to everything he said and
he's making all these changes but when
the changes are done I don't know if
he's going to get people through the
door this place oozes
Steakhouse I cannot tell
you look forward to
it how did you
say I can't afford to make many changes
cuz I can't afford to alienate or lose
what I have right now I'm
fuming D give me a little bit of
manhood I'm not insane I had a vision
you cooked a simple prime
rib that was your resurrection of the
place was a simple prime rib hey I've
got 12 successful RS highly profitable
and you my man missed out on a
trick when you change Concepts when you
change direction so radically I think
that's a sign of
weakness tomorrow we're changing the
menu we're going to relaunch the
restaurant you got some serious thinking
to do good
[Music]
night it's day four relaunch day and
time for Dean to embrace the changes
that will hopefully save his restaurant
Gordon secretly has brought in his
design team who worked through the night
to spruce up the Old Stone Mill you know
when I first arrived here yeah I drove
by this beautiful building without
actually realizing it was a
restaurant no sign no nothing let's have
a look Yes Man 1 2 3 up look at it
beautiful an Natural Stone The Old ston
Mill Steakhouse now we know what the
place is when we drive
by when they unveiled the sign it was
just absolutely beautiful I was breett
taken Dean you like him I love it huh
it's great very nice look next to it
Steak House yeah why didn't I do it call
the Sign Guy work out a barter with him
do a trade do something and get the sign
I could have I don't know why right
let's go inside there's
more history this is all the stuff
that's been upstairs that you've been
kept away so when customers aren't
waiting you know they can get an insight
to what you've done I want people to
know from the first minut they walk in
here that your heart is in here I was a
little intimidated when I first walked
in because I didn't know what to expect
every nook every bloody piece of stone
look the history is there Gordon putting
up these pictures of me building the
place blw me away okay there's more come
through
beautiful absolutely beautiful oh my
goodness wow now everybody can see
everybody oh it's lovely it's just
beautiful I can't even put it into words
it's open it's classic we've got new
plates new linen new table wear Barbara
what do you think got rid of the dark
colors too depressing yes too depressing
the candles on all the tables the fresh
flowers it's just bright it's cheer it's
a place you want to be I'm
speechless I'm
speechless the same restaurant is same
people but something is
different we have Gordon ramsy's touch
smell let's see if it works it has to
work it's there now there's no
excuse we've got rid of the Clutter look
at it looks great huh looks great I
didn't know what to expect I didn't know
any of this involved any kind of a
makeover of any sort but um I'm man
enough to admit that it's
great even though the improvements to
the decor are well received that was an
easy change to accept now for the hard
one the new Steakhouse menu okay let's
uh let's go through the food very very
quickly yes menu let's start off with
the um Meats that's the porterhouse
steak for two you got the most amazing
ribeye next to that you've got the New
York strip the most popular steak Across
America expected the blend of the old
and new but changing the menu completely
surprised me the most hbut has a really
nice sort of rustic meaty flavor you
know it's a very robust fish but panid
is beautiful and then the crispy skin
salmon spaghetti or squash comfy shalot
and a really nice crispy skin yes okay
the appetizers um steam muscles nice big
bowl and then the cream corome every
Steakhouse across the states has got
cream corn on there and then my favorite
the Old Stone meal chopped salad sadly
no
funnel this is going to be a challenge
but uh it's very exciting to have a new
Manu with 2 hours to go before the doors
open Gordon wants to make sure the
restaurant feels like the steakhouse in
town and before anyone eats any food it
will be up to the front of the house
staff this is now Steakhouse we're going
to confirm it each and every table that
arrives this evening a quick
presentation Bingo Tom sell it to
me my worries are that the food's
changed the Aesthetics have changed but
I still have my dysfunctional staff
hello welcome to the Old ston Mill
Steakhouse here are the steaks we have
this evening this is
our our 21 day
aged me let's go we have
a I'm completely out of my comfort zone
you can't expect to win the gold medal
in a week and on the top a Kobe strip
come on now a Kobe strip sounds like a
Japanese lap do it's still the
same mediocre crew in there God
Almighty Gordon has introduced a lot of
changes to the Old Stone Mill in just a
few days and with their heads still
reeling it's time for Dean and his staff
to rise to the occasion hello how are
you we're excited about tonight we're
hoping this goes over well for us can I
than
you're what do you think about the new
look G it's a new start we're exhausted
I'm emaciated I'm tired I'm anxious take
night tonight yeah I'm sure hope so I
was a little nervous going into it not
knowing a menu at all only seeing it
maybe at at 2 hours before we were
supposed to start not being ready is
always a fear okay this is the big nine
we put a plan together and now they have
to seriously execute it Kobe beef medium
rare I I'm stuck I like to know where
all the menus are if people drop the
ball
tonight you won't see them here
[Music]
tomorrow tonight is the night of the big
relaunch Gordon Ramsay's plan for a
steakhouse to fill the void in this town
has generated some Buzz is that the
mayor and the restaurant is fully booked
now it's up to Dean and his staff to
start building a new reputation for the
Old Stone Mill everybody is on their
tippy toes the mayor now where does the
big shot go tonight will certainly be an
indication of the probability of success
for this place hey hello Mr Mayor long
time no see I I was a little intimidated
when he first walked in because he's
important to me to be here take a coat
thanks when this place is full and the
mayor's here if you're not ready no I
don't care how good you are come on it's
not going to
work with the customers and special
guests taking their seats the servers
are busy making their rounds with a new
menu have the K the K be medium
well and it's obvious the pressure of
the relaunch is already getting to Tom
New York strip no I'm sorry the New York
strip the ribey and our Kobe beef
special
okay it was crazy I mean this whole
situation is crazy and the whole night
obviously from the beginning was going
to be
crazy get some
napkins done I'm
done I'm not comfortable with the
changes so quick when I don't know if
we're ready for it too much for me right
now I just need we need sorry I'll be
fine I really will we need you
while Tom tries to pull himself together
oh you a drw your eyes he and come back
as the manager Tom okay
okay the first wave of orders hits the
kitchen okay Michael watch your
temperature yeah I don't want the staks
coming back okay yes Che good Eight
party of eight who's eight whatever
eight eight comes in there was plenty of
pressure couple of times I lost my
composure let's go let's go Genie the
custom not castled and when Tom does
return he begins to feel the heat once
again that smell H H in here isn't
it
yes hat in that
kitchen I'm concerned about Tom he's
sweating like a pig I don't know what to
say I'll drive if you had too much don't
you
worry come here I got to talk you quick
now
right you're running around like a
blue ass fly yeah you're
sweating like a pig get in the bathroom
and do something about it when Tom came
back could see he was just totally dis
like disarranged he you know he was
nervous he was nervous got his
stinks it's 45 minutes into dinner
service and though all appears to be
going well melt like butter
taste only a few customers have been
served and the mayor is not one of them
they got a meltdown down there and the
uh mayor yeah we can't keep him waiting
yeah does Michael know that that's a
May's table what table number is that uh
that's 12 yeah to make sure he knows you
understand I need the mayor's table man
I'm not getting tickets through this
printer right now why I don't know this
printer right here is not working I'm
not getting tickets through this
computer it's going to me up no the
printer's
[Music]
working oh boy it was a disaster I've
already spoken to Dean about that and
and I finally screamed cursed and yells
get someone in here to fix this now or
we're I can't believe that no
one's coming in here to fix this
computer but if nobody wants to hear it
nobody wants to hear it how about those
Stakes how about those Stakes he's
standing there with his finger
up his ass I don't know if Dean
understands that'll sink the whole night
and you'll be done oh God now we're
seriously in the all the orders are
backed up tables are waiting Tom
switched off but more importantly we've
kept the mayor waiting 45 minutes of all
the people to keep waiting not the
mayor Christ now more than an
hour and 15 minutes into service and
hungry customers are getting
restless
it's will come soon it's getting a
little out of
control okay Michael
what I need is the may now
someone has to fix this computer cuz I'm
not getting
tickets unbelievable get me Dean
yeah please straight away yes Dean we
have to go in the kitchen I need the
mayor's table man I don't know it's a
hour it's not easy getting kicked in the
nuts every day and being told that you
suck I'm embarrassed man where I
told you
this I don't have tickets for this why
aren't I getting tickets for this please
help me I don't have Med the ticket is
what I'm saying but it this is
the copy you got to have the other half
this is not my ticket this comes from
the salad printer it's been an hour and
I got nothing read the ticket oh
H there we go what the read
the
ticket it's the last
table
I need the mayor's table man this is not
my ticket this comes from the salad
Critter it's been an hour and I got
nothing need the ticket oh
Hellie we go what the
need the
ticket it's the last
table how for the love of
Christ jinny 2 seconds yeah don't worry
about the coffee Mike Mike just
come around for 2 seconds please yes
with dinner service on the brink of
disaster Gordon lays it on the line for
Dean and his staff let's regroup a
little bit yeah let me just tell you the
situation service has gone we're all
over the place let's get this thing back
online we've got to make decisions
especially at this critical moment This
is Where I Need You Now to fight back
this is going to make a break this
place I was really really pissed off but
right now for the sake of the success
here I have to just get through it let's
get some appetizers I'll pump those out
real fast and then we'll get you in
there for your entrance you know what I
will be right back and I will wrap those
up for you you know at this point now
let's work together let's correct it
let's try to correct it sorry for the
delay give a steak Knife
please the printer is
working good deal it's getting there now
good deal two medium rare to
medium give me that it's 34 well Bona
petitte I certainly hope it was worth
the
wait
excellent and thankfully Dean gets
everyone focused there you go thank you
and the night at least finishes
[Music]
successfully the next day Gordon wants
to make sure that Dean's fear of failure
would no longer stand in the way of his
potential success what really pisses you
off the most what is it I know this
place is could be a raving success and
I'm not being blind and I'm not in the
dream world the fascinating
thing about you Dean is that you're
you're scared of failure walk a mile in
my shoes and then we'll talk I failed
before in business when when I opened a
restaurant up in my hometown thinking I
was the dog's bollocks and it made me
the person I am today having both
success and failure don't be scared you
can't keep on sidest stepping problems
but I really believe that he's doing it
for my career now I really believe him
perhaps deep down I knew that I needed
to change and I can't Overlook things
anymore you can't tiptoe over it this is
your
business you're right I got to implement
changes to make this work this time I
can't wait any
longer with a fresh new open-minded
attitude Dean masterfully took control
of the front of the house there we go
what else is having in the fling and the
back of the house that prime rib Looks
To Die For right there this is the steak
for real steak eaters Tom started to
gain the confidence he needs in his role
as manager did they get you drinks yet
you go yes you good and Michael has
rekindled his passion for cooking
Showtime
ladies and to honor the Old Stone Mill's
200th birthday Gordon organized a
celebration party for the community and
for you we'd like you to hang this also
the key of the city yonas wow getting
the key to the city blew me away I'm
excited for my husband because I see the
smile back in his face a
away the local news even took notice
putting the restaurant back in the
spotlight come and enjoy a steak at the
Old Stone Mill and the new Steakhouse
menu was just what this community needed
and wanted very good it's fantastic it
was excellent finally the food is now as
stunning as the building that it's
cooked
in the most important thing is the
confirmation that it can work the
potential is staggering now that you
know what to do don't stop doing it
thank you thank you very much thank
thank you my darling yes pleasure thank
you in my heart we're going to make it
we have to make it up high down below
you're too slow now get Gordon Ramsey
he's such a blessing to our family that
we could never ever thank him enough for
all that he's done for us I arrived I
found the place finally I thought it was
beautiful now I think you got something
phenomenal on now I have
something to really be proud of
thanks thank you good luck thanks man
I'm excited I'm excited about what the
future holds here do me a favor SNP
outside and have a quick look at the
front of the restaurant
oh how do they do it where is it
shooting from wow I've wanted to sign up
there for forever I'm just overwhelmed
tonight that is so
[Music]
cool